we gotta talk about this breaking news
man so here's the story
from the daily mail trump gives thumbs
up as he walks to marine one
to be medevaced to walter reed for covet
treatment
president releases video reassuring
americans he is doing well as son eric
asks
pray for my dad and white house says he
is staying in charge
we got some bullet points they say he
gave a thumbs up
he's expected to remain in the remain in
the hospital for a few days where the
white house says he will continue
working
as he traveled the video was posed at
the president's twitter account in which
he thanked the american people for their
support
and then i think it was jim acosta who
like tweeted a picture saying he won't
stop and talk to the press
it's like shocking yeah is that is that
his priority right now
but sure sure thanks for letting us know
the white house confirmed he had not
handed over
overpower to vice president pence
trump's son eric called him a true
warrior
as he asked for prayers for his recovery
on twitter trump and melania announced
they tested positive in the early hours
of friday morning
and were self-isolating in the white
house the first lady on friday tweeted
that she had mild symptoms but was
feeling good ivanka baron and jared
kushner have all tested negative
as has vice president mike pence joe
biden has uh
they go on to say he's 77 i guess but
that's that it doesn't matter
he says it negative so almost
immediately we're getting crazy
speculation
you know the first thing i thought when
i heard it's like whoa they're
airlifting trump i'm imagining like
trump like collapsing and
like the white house but he walks out
and he gives a thumbs up like it's no
big deal
yeah he wasn't out brought out on a
stretcher yeah yeah yeah
so naturally you like it's really funny
you know the circumstance isn't funny
but what's funny is the reaction how
because trump isn't collapsing you know
and
and gasping for air it must be a
conspiracy
trump's not really sick he's just trying
to steal back the news cycle
well you know they they talk about how
devastating kovat is but you know or the
the mainstream media will have you think
oh like they have the death count
on cnn and yeah yeah yeah you know but
it's it's not a death sentence you know
uh
i i think that trump's gonna probably
come out of this
okay what do you think does it just end
up with like
a week goes by trump's fine or i mean
it's 2020 man come on we're talking
apocalyptic level fiction
and sci-fi kind of didn't you say an
experimental treatment
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so so trump
received
regeneron's experimental antibody drug
for his coronavirus symptoms
the experimental treatment is still in
clinical trials
so he's gonna be a zombie he's gonna
what if he comes out he's like he looks
like he's 50 whoa
stem cells he's super ripped and he's
like standing there and like his muscles
rip his shirt
he's like i feel better than ever listen
i feel better
than ever everyone agrees like super
hulk
that'd be an instant vote from me yeah
that would be awesome so he's basically
hijacking the news cycle whether he
intend means to or not right
yeah yeah i mean yeah you think the way
he came out on top
came out ahead he was like we're coming
out ahead on this one so he like
posted on twitter immediately when they
found out was like we're gonna milk this
i don't think there's any conspiracy or
anything like that man i think
uh a ton of people got covet right so
um was it mike lee i think right yeah
yeah and and ronald mcdaniel
yep and there's a video of mikey like
hugging everybody at this like amy coney
barrett
nomination thing so you know what's
really funny there's a tweet
and uh i can't remember who tweeted they
were like why is it that so many
republicans are getting coveted and so
many
high-profile democrats aren't and it's
like well
you know republicans a lot of them
aren't wearing masks ralph northern i
got it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i thought he was a republican
because he was wearing the kkk uh
oh that's right isn't he republican yeah
i don't know oh wait what do we do
which one which one is the racist one
again which party is it
i love it it's like uh we uh there's a
picture of me
i'm not sure which one i was i can't
remember
whether i was wearing uh you know makeup
on my face or just like a hood
yeah couldn't tell ya couldn't tell ya
pick one they're both great all right i
absolutely have to read
a super chat right here in this segment
because it's hilarious
so uh mark says hey tim imagine if trump
has
the cure in his antibodies the cure
would have trump's dna in the
vaccination
and uh what is it and people will freak
out then
could you well actually think about this
i think you mentioned something about
south park imagine if trump gets this
and then they're like he has mild
symptoms and then like by tomorrow he's
totally fine
and they're like this is strange he's
completely cured so they do a blood test
and find that trump
his blood has the specific antibody that
they need for the cure
and then they go to all the leftists and
they're like we have to inject you with
you know this vaccine
with trump's dna like we're literally
going to put trump
in your veins now i don't think anything
like that will really happen
you know but it's a but it's so many
people it doesn't sound like i wouldn't
take
it i'd rather die i have nothing to do
with him yeah
i mean it doesn't sound that far-fetched
but you know
i i don't know it's 20 20 man bring it
on
what what if this what if the opposite
happened well what if it was with biden
what if biden
uh contracted the virus and and it was
in his dna would you take
would you take the biden vaccine or why
not or
i don't know look i i think if the
companies do testing and the vaccine
comes out i'm not
i'm not worried that like a bunch of
people are going to turn into zombies or
like drop dead or become
biden or something you know like i i
always think about i am legend where
they're like we have this cure for
cancer
everybody takes it it's fine no problem
and then suddenly
you know there's like the last person on
earth is will smith
yeah but they were the movie ruined the
actual story yeah
like the the actual story was that once
everyone was it was a vampire was like a
zombie mutant whatever
he was the legendary monster who lurked
in the while they slept killing them get
it
sure okay the movie didn't do that the
movie totally missed the concept
i see yeah yeah so i've actually i've
actually referenced you know that that
you know i've referenced i am legend in
the context of like social justice and
you know identitarianism on the left
like there will come a point where
when the entire country has adopted this
ideology you
are the fringe zealot weirdo with crazy
ideas and then it's like that's kind of
like the same idea you know like
everyone becomes a zombie because they
take the biden vaccine i'm
but there's something about rushing out
of medicine that a horde of people would
take without
proper clinical trials you're supposed
to be in clinical trials for years yeah
stuff yeah that's why i think it's like
i'll wait a little bit
you know i'm not gonna you know if if
they announced a vaccine
i'm not gonna rout the door full speed
throw my coat and like go 90 miles an
hour i'm going to be like yeah
i mean well first of all you can anyway
um because
they're going to give it to frontline
workers right exactly so
uh you know let them you know let them
see what happens
you know let's see are you interested in
the big scene um
pass no i i don't know i
uh i i i look at it this way i i don't
think i necessarily have a problem with
there's there's so many
people there there's so many companies
that are working on the same thing
so if they all kind of come to the same
conclusion
maybe you know uh i just i just don't
think
that there's you know maybe there's
going to be malpractice maybe there will
be
mistakes maybe like you said the
clinical trial is supposed to take a
long time
and trump scott was at operation warp
speed i think it's called yeah
yeah so uh i mean i don't know if i want
to take a vaccine that's been like
mass produced and pumped out by a major
pharmaceutical in only a few months you
know are we supposed to wait until
like coveted 23 hits and then we is that
why it's called 19 why is it why is it
called 19 because uh it was 2019 because
it came from 2019. yeah
is that it so then kobe 23 we'll have
four years yeah and then we're on cover
24 we're gonna have the yearly coveted
naming them like hurricanes well
actually we'll we'll probably only have
a coveted like every
like once every four years probably you
know but only when are republicans in
the white house yeah i think
yeah yeah yeah yeah every time a
republican gets elected it's like oh
copenhagen's back
lock the economy down i think it has
something to do with global warming i'm
gonna go there because like if
they say that like bacteria and stuff
can lie dormant under the glaciers and
as they recede that that it it releases
new
i heard about that that's where the
covet came from i wonder if that is
global warming
because it just appears they're gonna
make a movie like this because you know
how they did like the comey was it the
comey report or something
was that they call me something yeah
yeah have you seen it no i thought the
trailer was was a parody
i thought it was like gonna be like you
know funny or die or like the onion
right it was really bad but anyway
they're gonna like they're gonna make a
movie out of this
and they're gonna they're gonna they're
gonna have you know trump and it's gonna
be like elk baldwin just really
horrible impression and it's gonna be
like some climate change researchers
and they're gonna watch like the larsen
be ice shelf break and it's gonna be
um what's that guy's name his brother
dennis quaid
that's his name right he was in the
movie the after tomorrow was that him
randy quaid randy no randy those guys
are brothers though
randy's the one oh i'm sorry i'm yeah
randy's the crazy one who's got the
crazy beard
i was thinking independence day that's
that was randy yeah that was randy yes
the end of tomorrow was dennis quaid
yeah so they're gonna have him like the
the shelf breaks but instead of b him
being like
oh no it's gonna disrupt the current a
green fog is gonna come out and he's
gonna go
ah and then that's going to show him
like at the council being like the
coronavirus escaped the ice
i mean i'm being silly but actually in
brings up a good point because they've
been talking about like
viruses and bacteria that are trapped in
ice that when it melts they get released
i mean if it brings about maybe like a
zombie apocalypse at this point i'm just
it's the waiting i can't stand you know
just get it done
weinstein brett weinstein was saying
that it was like an ancient
virus covid was yeah
i don't know maybe i don't know about it
i don't believe that but i don't have
any
other evidence to the contrary but i
don't have the wherewithal to defend
myself
i saw uh there's a funny meme going
around it's you know that picture of
trump eating the taco bowl
it's it's of him but it's a it's a soup
with a bat in it
please tell me he made it into my way i
have to know
please tell me somebody on his staff
like just made it up or maybe like uh
uh a dunk them maybe no i don't know
if somebody somebody made the meme and
they're shang it around thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you